How can one naturally eliminate kidney stones?
Well, you can't always.
So the general medical way of eliminating kidney stones,
number one is to wait till they pass
and to give a person pain medication until they pass.
You can go in there and surgically remove them.
You can go in there and use laser removement
of kidney stones.
Eurologist typically would do those procedures.
From a natural perspective, we have a herbal product
that is called stoned something,
something for kidney stones.
I'd like to look up the name of that product.
It's, let's see what it is.
It's called stoned breaker.
It's a product from herb farm
and it has some different herbs in there
that have been helpful for kidney stones.
Have we used that successfully?
I don't know.
I don't, it's not something that we treat on a regular basis
or talk about on a regular basis.
So I know I've referred people to use that product
in the past, but I don't know if that helped them.
I didn't get a report back quite honestly.
So.